>>> MEMBERS OF THE OATH KEEPERS
ALLEGEDLY MAKING PREPARATIONS
FOR VIOLENCE BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
LET IT COME.
I'M WILLING TO SACRIFICE
MYSELF.
IF THEY THROW BOMBS AT US AND
SHOOT US, GREAT.
YOU DO NOT WANT TO WASTE THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
>> FEDERAL PROSECUTORS PLAYED
THE AUDIO FROM THE OATHKEEPERS
FOUNDERS ON THE SECOND DAY OF
THE THE SEDITION.
TASHA, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING.
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY KNOWN STEWART A
LOT LONGER THAN THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
WAYS.
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT RECORDING,
WHAT DO YOU HEAR?
>> IT'S JUST HOW STEWART TALKED.
I CAN'T COUNT THE NUMBER OF
TIMES I'VE HEARD THAT THERE WAS
A QUOTE IN THERE, DON'T MAKE IT
EASY TO GET A CONSPIRACY CHARGE
AND THIS WAS A PHRASE I HEARD
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT SOMEONE
FINALLY RECORDED HIM SAYING IT.
HE WOULD HUDDLE HIS GUY UP LIKE
A FOOTBALL TEAM BEFORE THEY WENT
OUT AND GIVE THEM A LECTURE ON
CONSPIRACY AND WHY THAT YOUR AT
RISK FOR IT.
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE HE WAS
SO GOOD AT WALKING THOSE LEGAL
LINES.
EACH INDIVIDUAL ACT WOULD IN
MOST CASES BE CONSIDERED
TECHNICALLY LEGAL, JUST NOT WHEN
YOU PUT IT ALL TOGETHER, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY WERE, YOU
KNOW, PLANNING TO DO EVENTUALLY.
>> LET ME ACTUALLY PLAY THE
EXACT CLIP YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THERE WHERE HE REFERS TO THE
NOTION OF A CONSPIRACY.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THIS PHONE CALLED IS BEING
RECORDED BY THE NSA AND FBI ARE
URGING YOU TO SAY IT IS AGAINST
YOU.
DON'T MAKE IT EASY FOR THEM TO
POP YOU WITH A CONSPIRACY
CHARGE.
THOSE GUYS FROM MICHIGAN
PROBABLY AFTER A FEW BEERS
TALKING SMACK, BE DISCIPLINED.
>> YOU HEAR HIS LEGAL MIND, YALE
LAW GRADUATE, HIS LEGAL MIND AT
WORK THERE.
>> YES.
THAT WAS SOMETHING HE WAS HYPER
AWARE OF.
YOU HEAR HIM SAYING THIS CALL IS
PROBABLY BEING MONITORED.
THAT'S HOW HE LIVED.
HE SPOKE IN THE HOUSE AS THOUGH
HE WAS CONTINUALLY BEING
MONITORED AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
IT WAS WHY I WAS SO AFRAID HE
HAD NOT BEEN ARRESTED.
I THOUGHT MAYBE HE HAD WALKED
THAT LINE JUST FINE ENOUGH BUT I
DON'T THINK HE DID THIS TIME
WHAT'S HIS RELATIONSHIP OR
ATTITUDE TOWARD VIOLENCE?
>> HE HAS NO LIMITS WHEN IT
COMES TO VIOLENCE.
HIS ONLY LIMIT ON VIOLENCE IS
WHAT DOES HE THINK HE CAN GET
AWAY WITH.
THOUGH HE IS RISK ADVERSE FOR
HIMSELF, HE DOESN'T WANT TO GET
HURT, HE CERTAINLY HAS NOT
LIMITS ON ENGINEERING VIOLENCE
FROM THE OTHER SIDE, FROM NO
LIMITS ON JUSTIFYING IT FOR
ANYTHING THAT HE THINKS IS A
GOOD CAUSE, WHATEVER THAT MAY BE
AT ANY GIVEN TIME AND THAT CAN
CHANGE WITH SOMEONE LIKE HIM.
>> HOW MUCH FAITH DO YOU BELIEVE
HE HAD IN OTHERS TO WALK THE
LINE THAT HE'S CALLING ON THEM
TO ACT AND FOR OTHERS TO BEHAVE
IN THE WAY HE WAS HOPING, NAMELY
THE FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP?
>> HE REALLY BELIEVED HE COULD
CONTROL PEOPLE WITH HIS VOICE,
AS LONG AS HE GOT IN FRONT OF
THEM, WHICH IS WHY I DID BELIEVE
THAT THERE WAS A MOMENT WHERE HE
ASKED TO SPEAK TO TRUMP
DIRECTLY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HIM.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE WAS BECOMING
FEARFUL AND HE WANTED TO REGAIN
THAT CONTROL AND WANTED TO USE
HIS VOICE TO MANIPULATE EVEN
DONALD TRUMP.
>> IN IS A COURT CASE.
AND A JURY COULD DECIDE THAT HE
IS NOT GUILTY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENS IF
STEWART ROSE IS FOUND NOT
GUILTY?
>> IF HE IS FOUND NOT GUILTY, HE
RISES AGAIN.
THE ONLY THING STOPPING HIM FROM
BEING THE GREAT HERO ON THE
EXTREME RIGHT WAS THAT FOR A
SHORT TIME THERE THEY SUSPECTED
HE MIGHT BE SOME TYPE OF
INFORMANT.
WELL, NOW HE'S PAID HIS DUES IN
THAT DEPARTMENT, HE'S BEEN IN
JAIL.
I BELIEVE HE EVEN SAID GOING TO
JAIL WOULD HELP HIM IN THE
MOVEMENT, AT LEAST IN THE EYES
OF THE MOVEMENT.
THERE'S NOTHING IF HE'S
ACQUITTED STOPPING HIM FROM
RISING UP, BECOMING A GREAT HERO
AND A MARTYR AND A LEADER ALL AT